sur les lieux de travail l'odeur qui
accompagnent les maîtres poisson
réchauffer suscite souvent des débats du
poisson vous ferez ça sent surtout la
marque aux anneaux des mines ça sent la
mer ça sent pas du poisson qui pue le
poisson frais ce consensus et des promos
félin s'est décomposé que son produit
naturellement et que les poissons
mangent et que nous on va sentir la
nature à donner aux poissons des
molécules afin de les protéger du froid
lorsque le poisson y mord les bactéries
et les enzymes propre du poisson qui
vont transformer cette molécule à antrim
et si la mine et c'est ça la molécule
qu'on identifie comme le poisson qui pue
le poisson ce processus de dégradation
commence au moment de la capture
après six sept huit jours l'odeur des
trimestre la mine est très puissant et
après ça ça devient même ammoniacal à
plus certains poissons très gras à chair
blanche où on va dire blanc le cas c'est
comme la sardine le maquereau ont
beaucoup d'acides aminés dans le liquide
cellulaire ce qui fait qu'en plus il va
voir une production d'ammoniac par
l'action des bactéries et des enzymes
qui va survenir plus rapidement donc
plus le poisson est vrai - il sent le
poisson avant de l'acheter on utilise
notre nez si une grande quantité de trim
et il a mis n'est présente
l'odeur sera perceptible même à travers
l'emballage deuxième chose à regarder
il faut regarder s'il ya du jus
l'absence de justin boxing ça veut dire
que les poissons y tient encore à
touchant la texture du poisson aussi
s'ils restent ensemble et qui se détache
pas un flocon
c'est un bon indicateur qui les ferait
avant la cuisson
certains gestes simples pour atténuer
les odeurs désagréables
aures aures les simple fait de reims et
à boisson mais ça va réduire la quantité
des tris mais si la mine surtout en
surface bien sûr les primes et dynamique
qui est produite plus à l'intérieur dans
les interstices des musées mais ça ça va
rester là et ça malheureusement ovale
sentir lors de la cuisson est ce qu'on
aura un avantage enlever la peau voilà
la question
je pense pas que a levé la peau va faire
en sorte que le trimestre si la mine va
diminuer de façon importante
par contre le goût du poisson globale va
diminuer pourquoi parce que entre la
peau et le filet il ya aussi un petit
char qui contient beaucoup de gras et ça
il ya beaucoup de composants de saveurs
autre que maintenant
la robe haute qu'elle a trimé dynamique
a ajouté un incident peut aussi aider
faire cuire du poisson dans un bouillon
avec du vinaigre du jus de citron ou
tout autre acide peut aider à diminuer
l'intensité de la tri médecine malgré
tout l'odeur peut être désagréable
lorsqu on réchauffe un poisson pris
cloud
dès qu'on commence à chauffer et
commence à voir de la vapeur qui se
dégage de cette ba par love a entraîné
la trimestre la mine et elle va se
répandre partout dans l'air ambiant
quand on cuisine c'est normal que se
sentent light c'est normal que ça sang
de l'agneau
c'est normal que ça sent bon le repas et
l'odeur de poisson ça vient avec le
report par contre la perception qu'a
donnée dans un bureau fermé avec une
petite fenêtre comme ça et qu'on met son
micro ondes
surtout quand on est une personne sur 25
allemands gb ça peut être devenir très
incommode à la meilleure façon
d'éliminer des odeurs de poisson c'est
ouvrir les fenêtres pour éviter
d'incommoder les collègues au bureau on
peut manger son poisson froide en salade
ou encore manger autre chose
[Musique]